[Music]  now sadly TJ Miller could not join us  because he is shooting a film with  Steven Spielberg ready player one and  he's in London right now Martin Starr  could not be with us because he is in  spider-man homecoming yeah didn't know  that yeah but he's in Atlanta shooting  and he was kind enough to make us a  little video message so I don't know if  I think we can roll that now sorry I  couldn't be there to hang out with you  all in person not individually but you  know up on stage would be still very far  apart but we'd be closer than we are  currently which is I'm across the  country more towards the East Coast  working on a movie called Spider Man  play it feel like I've done what I  needed to do here  say hello give you an important detail  on the movie that you didn't have prior  and I'm sure you're all very curious  about my play I don't know I don't have  like an official sign-off so goodbye  mark does shades of guilfoyle in  martinez quintessentially  you